Estoy animado por mejorar
mi flexibilidad corporal,
por lo cual he decidido
tomar unas clases de yoga.
Me presenté al lugar de las clases de yoga
llamado Súper Yoga, y les pregunté,
¿cuánto cuestan las clases?
A lo cual me respondieron,
"tenemos el plan básico y el plan de prueba,
en el plan de prueba  tú puedes venir a probar las clases
por lo cual te va a costar 12 dólares
por sesión de 1 hora,
pero si te gustan las clases,
puedes adquirir una membresía mensual,
pagarías 20 dólares por mes
en lo que se llama el plan básico,
son 20 dólares por mes y tienes un descuento por sesión, solo pagas 8 dólares por sesión".
Esto me parece interesante
pero estoy un poco confundido,
¿cuál es el plan que me conviene?
Para ver esto,
yo empezaría preguntándome,
¿cuánto pagaría de acuerdo a cada plan según el número de sesiones que voy a tomar?
Y para facilitar este trabajo,
vamos a definir algunas variables,
llamémosle "s" al número de sesiones
que voy a asistir mensualmente,
al número de sesiones por mes...
el número de sesiones a las que asistiré
mensualmente en Súper Yoga.
Digamos que "c" es el costo mensual total...
el costo mensual total.
Así es que con estas variables así definidas,
veamos cuanto me costará cada uno de los planes
dependiendo del número de sesiones
que voy a tomar.
Lo que aquí vamos a hacer
es voy a empezar con el plan de prueba,
se ve más simple este plan de prueba,
para esto voy a hacer una tabla con el costo...
No, voy a empezar la tabla mejor con el número
de sesiones y el costo para ese número de sesiones.
Ésta sería nuestra pequeña tabla
para el plan de prueba
y también voy a hacer
una pequeña tabla para el plan básico,
dado que queremos
comparar ambos planes,
el plan básico
y el plan de prueba.
Nuestra tabla para el plan básico también
incluiría el número de sesiones
y el costo total correspondiente
a ese número de sesiones.
Pensemos entonces qué pasa para empezar
si decido no asistir a ninguna sesión,
si decido asistir a 0 sesiones, en el plan de prueba,
¿cuál será el costo?
Bien, 12 dólares por sesión,
12 dólares por 0 sesiones,
no voy a tener que pagar nada,
el costo total va a ser 0.
Ahora,
¿qué pasa con la misma situación en el plan básico?
Si tengo el plan básico y en un mes dado
no asisto a ninguna sesión,
no asisto al estudio...
no asiste al estudio Súper Yoga para nada,
¿cuánto entonces voy a pagar?
Son 8 dólares por sesión,
pero no fui a ninguna sesión,
así es que no voy a pagar nada por el costo de sesión, pero sí tengo que pagar los 20 dólares por mes.
Así es que si voy a pagar 20 dólares,
aunque no haya asistido a ninguna sesión,
esta opción realmente no es atractiva
bajo el plan básico.
Veamos otras opciones.
Consideremos ahora la opción
en que asisto a una sesión,
la opción de que asisto a una sesión bajo
el plan de prueba son 12 dólares por sesión,
serían 12 dólares por sesión,
por una sesión,
eso sería 12 dólares lo que pagaría
al mes por una sesión en el plan de prueba.
¿qué pasa con el plan básico?
Con el plan básico,
por una sesión...
con el plan básico por una sesión
pagaría 8 dólares por sesión,
por una sesión serían 8 dólares
más la cuota fija de 20 dólares al mes.
Así es que sería 20 más 8, 28 dólares
al mes que pagaría por una sesión con el plan básico.
Aún sigue siendo más conveniente el plan de prueba,
asistiendo a tan solo una sesión,
así es que esto es 20 dólares y aquí tenemos,
28 dólares.
Y podría seguir con estas tablas,
de hecho te invito a que lo hagas,
que sigas llenando estas tablas
para que percibas cómo se van dando los números.
Si asisto a dos sesiones,
con el plan de prueba,
tendría que pagar 12 por sesión
por dos sesiones pagaría 24 dólares,
en cambio,
en el plan básico si yo asisto a dos sesiones...
lo voy a hacer en amarillo...
si asisto a dos sesiones pagaría 8 dólares por sesión,
8 por 2 más 20 dólares del pago mensual,
es decir, pagaría...
vamos a desglosar el pago...
pagaría 2 por 8 más el pago mensual de 20 dólares,
esto es igual, 2 por 8 = 16 más
20 = 36 dólares es lo que pagaría.
Así es que al menos para 0,
1 ó 2 sesiones que tenemos aquí,
el plan de prueba
sigue siendo el más conveniente.
Lo que quiero hacer, es encontrar en que punto es más conveniente el plan básico que el plan de prueba,
pero antes de hacer eso,
veamos si podemos representar esto
de una manera más algebraica,
pues eso es lo que nos va a permitir responder
de manera precisa a nuestras preguntas.
Si consideramos que "s" es el número de sesiones
por mes y "c" es el costo mensual,
¿cómo podemos representar
el plan de prueba con una ecuación?
Bueno, nuestro costo mensual total,
nuestro costo mensual total "c"...
y esto es para el plan de prueba...
déjame poner aquí una línea punteada...
una línea punteada
para separar el plan de prueba...
nuestro costo total mensual
va a ser igual a 12 dólares por sesión,
es decir, 12 que multiplica a el número
de sesiones que es "s",
12 por "s", así es que para el plan de prueba,
puedo establecer que el costo total mensual
es igual a 12 dólares
por el número de sesiones
o 12 dólares por sesión
por el número de sesiones.
Hagamos lo mismo para el plan básico.
¿Cómo podemos expresar esto
con una ecuación?
Tenemos que nuestro costo total mensual
que hemos llamado "c",
esto va a ser igual a... bueno,
sin importar lo que hagamos,
vamos a tener que pagar 20 dólares por mes,
sin importar si tomamos sesiones o no,
tenemos que pagar 20 dólares por mes, es decir,
ese costo total va a ser igual a 20,
al cual le vamos a sumar
8 dólares por sesión.
20 del costo mensual fijo,
más 8 dólares que
tenemos que pagar por cada sesión,
es decir, 20 más 8
por el número de sesiones "s", 20 más "8s".
Y podemos verificar
que si tenemos 0 sesiones,
tendríamos 0 aquí y el resultado sería
20 más 8 por 0,
20 dólares, si tenemos 1 sesión, "s" sería 1,
20 más 8 por 1 = 28 dólares,
podemos ver entonces que estos valores
de "s" y "c" cumplen con la ecuación.
Lo mismo pasa aquí, podríamos inclusive
generar más valores,
lo que es realmente extraordinario
de estas ecuaciones,
esta simple ecuación describe todas las opciones
que tenemos aquí y esta simple ecuación comprende,
describe, abarca todas las opciones
que tenemos aquí.
En los siguientes videos,
lo que voy a hacer
es explorar como podemos usar
estas dos ecuaciones
para darme claridad
acerca de cuál es plan más conveniente.